il ya le nouveau savoir ce qui est sorti
le nouveau star voir ce quoi je passe je
passe souvent des contrefaçons vous
l'avez vu - non donc voilà je ne veux
pas fait un critique du film qu'on n'a
aucun sens puisque je n'ai pas eu non
par contre je remettais les anciens et
je me suis mis à la place d'un site et
je me suis que lil jon a été quand même
assez méchant du coup je me suis demandé
qu'est ce qui a vraiment un côté obscur
de la force
mais las vous connaissez pas star wars
et ben j'espère sincèrement que tout va
bien dans notre monde parallèle pour les
autres vous inquiétez pas il y aura du
coup aucun spoil sur l'épisode 7 puisque
j'ai toujours pas vu depuis de
génériques j'ai toujours kiffé star wars
et notamment pour un truc que je trouve
incroyable c'est la force à cette
énergie qui est dans tout l'univers
comme dirait ben kenobi elle nous
entoure et nous pénètre
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour benkadi
vraiment elle nous entoure et nous
pénètre c'est ce qu'il dit la galaxie en
1 to unis
à moi ça me fait vachement penser à la
définition de dieu de spinoza dont je
vous avais déjà parlé dans un coup de
fil je mets le lien en descriptions mais
ce que je retiens ici c'est l'idée du
tous unis or dans la force
il ya deux côtés distincts et a le côté
obscur et le côté clair mais oui c'est
clair ils sont distincts à tous les
niveaux il ya par exemple des musiques
différentes tintin tintin tintin
ils ont aussi des couleurs très marqué
tous les jedi sont en blanc tous les
sites sont en noir genre au point où ils
peuvent même pas faire leur lessive
ensemble ils ont des vaisseaux différent
des méthodes différentes et pouvoirs
différents bref tout un tas de trucs
différents
en fait vu que la force soit un tout
unique et que ces deux aspects bas sont
en fait la négation l'un de l'autre
c'est à dire que ce qui n'est pas clair
et obscur
est-ce qu'il n'est pas obscures est
claire m en fait on a un petit peu un
équilibre et si ces deux côtés forme un
équilibre alors ils ont chacun besoin de
l'autre pour exister
alors en plus de ça parfois ça
s'équilibre tout seul par exemple anakin
il est passé du côté obscur en devint
dark vador et d'ailleurs on peut noter
que c'est l'amour qui l'a fait basculer
l'amour qu'il ressentait pour pas nommé
ah oui c'est aussi par peur mais c'est
une peur qui n'est pas ce qu'il tient
pas nommé mais on reparlera de la peur
plus tard
bref on peut effectivement passés du
côté clair au côté obscur à ce qu'on
peut faire l' inverse
oui il ya en solo par exemple en solo à
la base un contrebandier il fuit la
galaxie il a des dettes énormes le passe
son temps à draguer de la meuf il est
tellement arrogant que le seul être qui
le supportent
c'est une boule de poils va pas me dire
qu'il est du côté clair de la force
et pourtant il y passe puisque rejoint
une cause la cause des rebelles et qu'il
n'agit plus pour lui mais pour un idéal
qui le dépasse un idéal qui représente
le côté clair de la force en plus voilà
et notez aussi que il le fait ce
basculement par amour également à la
main en tout cas ces deux côtés de la
force
ils sont perméables alors qu'est-ce qui
fait qu'alain qu'ils soient obscur et
l'autre clair en fait je pense que ça va
aussi reprendre ou alors vous connaissez
mal mais en gros la différence est
minime déjà son plein le côté obscur il
est obscur bas parce qu'ils représentent
et parlent empire c'est des gens qui
sont au dessus des lois
c'est des gens qui tuent pour leurs
idées c'est des gens qui sont animés par
la haine et qui font des masques beauté
non homologué par un job phoenix et si
on parlait un peu du côté clair de la
force
eh ben ils sont aussi au dessus des lois
en fait le concept des jedi qu'on les
voit que palpatine est enfin de prendre
le pouvoir
il décide de se battre alors que je suis
désolé mais palpatine il est dans son
droit
alors certes il a menti dans ses
intentions mais il est dans le système
tu vois genre on vote pour lui il a une
légitimité
or les jedi ils sont prêts à affronter
ça est ce que fait mme nasreen doukan et
l'arrêt de contre palpatine pour
l'arrêter et se battre contre lui mais
c'est un coup d'état et que même en
règle générale les jedi c'est des
chevaliers ils tuent pour leurs idées
vous me direz peut-être il tue pas par
là m ah oui vraiment et puis même dans
leur manière d'exécuter l'action soit
les jedi ou les sites il se bat avec la
même arme le sabre laser tu vois il se
cache pas derrière des petits blaster à
distance non non là c'est les yeux dans
les yeux avec l'art noble de la maîtrise
du sabre
enfin c'est quand même une arme de
vérité et c'est des sabres qui peu
importe la couleur illumine éclair et
sont sources de lumière fois un point au
genre tu prends le général grievous tout
le retourne ça fait un lustre alors je
suis pas du tout en train de dire que
les jedi sont des sites et vice versa ou
plus côté obscur n'existe pas lorsque je
veux juste faire ses nuances et un petit
peu cette image qu on est star wars et
de ce côté obscur versus côté clair
finalement les deux côtés ils sont prêts
pour eux on se rend compte que
la différence entre ces deux côtés c'est
patent de vouloir faire le bien absolu
ou le mal absolu
c'est à dire d'être un absolu méchant ou
un absolu gentil mais c'est plus un
système de valeurs subjectives quoi et
ça rejoint ce que j'avais dit dans le
casque cyrus north numéro un dans la
description et au global dans les faits
on a une vraie position entre d'un côté
un environnement clair donc la
république jusqu'à un environnement
obscur lempire et ça se faire en
parallèle avec la transition d'anakin
qui passe du côté clair au côté obscur
de la force
et les deux ont le même moteur la peur
mène à la colère colère mène à la lan
alors anakin on en a parlé tout à
l'heure mais pour la république m'a
palpatine il s'est montré comme le plus
apte à gérer les problèmes de la
république c'est des problèmes qui
faisait peur aux citoyens et du coup
sans le comprendre
ils ont élu quelqu'un au sein de la
république qu'ils attribuent leurs
droits il a fait la république un empire
lempire n'a pas renversé la république
lempire c'est la république
pas de star wars ça ne monte que un
politicien peut profiter du sentiment de
peur pour affaiblir la république
[ __ ] le pen s'est pas patine en fait
sauf que nous on n'a pas de jedis enfin
on a le jeudi mais ça sert à rien dans
ce cas là après le jeudi en soit c'est
cool moi j'aime bien ça
et puis on aurait pu se poser d'autres
questions sur luc par exemple regarde le
mec il a pas d'amis ils cherchent un
groupe dans lequel il peut donner un
sens à sa vie
il s'est formé à l'art de la guerre par
des fanatiques
il est prêt à détruire des trucs immense
et y laisser sa vie ne serait pas un
terroriste radicalisé par alvin c'est
une idée que j'ai trouvé amusante qui
est issu d'un article de slate que je
mets dans la description fois que je
rate ma séance
bref voilà petite réflexion sur star
wars j'espère que ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à développer et à débattre
de ce don rouler dans les commentaires
c'est fait pour ça ça c'était juste une
approche une optique il y en a plein
d'autres
donc voilà j'espère que ça vous a plu et
surtout abonnez-vous si c'est pas le cas
pour pas rater les prochaines vidéos on
aurait pu parler de plein d'autres
choses toute façon je pense refaire un
pop up sur star wars vous trouverez ici
le pop est numéro un sur retour va le
tueur fut et si le dernier épisode du
coup de fil sur hegel
on se revoit dans deux semaines je
souhaite un joyeux noël et de belles
fêtes de fin d'année nous envoie du love
et de la piste évolue au noyau l'eau